hey everyone this is feeding master
kostikova tsuki here for chess comp and
today I want to talk to you guys about a
certain mindset or attitude that you
should have when playing chess and what
I want to recommend to you guys is to
always search for the most active
solution to your problems and what does
that mean that's kind of a very vague
statement but what that means is after
you leave the opening you're going to
have to make certain decisions right
once you leave your knowledge of
openings and opening Theory you're going
to have to develop a plan you're going
to have to find a way to improve that
your position improve the position of
your pieces solidify any weaknesses you
might have and also look for ways to
attack and assault your opponent's
position so there are a lot of decisions
that need to be made in this sort of
transition stage from the opening to the
middle game and one particular decision
that I think a lot of inexperienced
players have trouble with is trying to
find the defense when their opponent
makes some kind of threat any kind of
threat right take a look at the position
we have White's last move was Queen c3
with the threat of Queen take c7 so
right now would be a great time to pause
the video and figure out how you would
play here as black and I strongly
strongly recommend that you pause the
video and take at least three to five
minutes evaluating the position trying
to figure out what's going on and trying
to find the best move for black here to
deal with this threat of Queen take c7
okay assuming you've already paused your
videos we're going to move on so the
first thing you need to do when
when you see any sort of new position is
evaluated you need to figure out who's
better and why right in this case I
would say that white definitely has the
advantage here not a whole huge
advantage but at least a slight
advantage and that's because he controls
more space with his efore pond and his
pieces are more centrally placed and
more active than black's pieces so this
isn't a huge deal so far but it's
important to recognize that white is the
one who has the upper hand here so the
next thing you need to do here is ask
yourself is my opponent actually
threatening anything okay let's say for
example we passed the turn and let white
make another move so Knight takes c7 we
can play rook c8 the knight is lined up
with the Queen so we play rook c8 to pin
it and win it so if white did this on
his next turn and we played rook c8 we
would win the piece and we would
probably win the game so Knight takes e7
isn't a threat how about Queen take C 7
now here I don't see a good way for
black to continue right anything we do
attacking this Queen like rook c8 or
moving this Knight to open up the 7 rook
against the Queen y can simply trade
Queens and play the endgame with at
least one extra pawn right so the only
forcing move here is Queen take c7 and
then after white plays Knight take C 7
then you would stop and think to see if
black can sort of do anything here so
the next move you should look at here is
rook c8 attacking the knight and
x-raying the pawn on c2 but the problem
with this move is that white can simply
play 95 attacking blacks of the rook and
then after this rook moves Y can play
something like c3 and they'll have an
extra pawn in the endgame with a huge
advantage so Queen take c7 is a threat
right we've established that we've
evaluated what happens and we know that
it's something we have to deal with so
now what how do
defend against this threat and here's
where I want to really talk about how
you should be looking for the most
active solution Blanc has a couple of
different ways here to defend this pawn
the most obvious way is moving this
Knight okay I guess the most most
obvious ways pushing this pawn or plain
rook c8 but you can probably realize
pretty quickly that moving the rook to
c8 hangs the a7 pawn and pushing our C
pawn would hang the d6 pawn so these
options we can just immediately rule out
because they lose material so the most
obvious option that doesn't lose
material is moving this d7 Knight
somewhere and opening up our East 7 rug
to control the c7 square and defend the
pawn so for example 95 here it's
probably a move that a lot of you would
have played defending the pawn and
putting the knight on a better square in
the center so this move looks really
good but there is a problem with it and
that problem is that blacks position
still remains kind of passive right the
Queen on d8 isn't activated the rook on
a8 is doing absolutely nothing and this
rook on e7 it's only real job is
defending the c7 pawn right it's no
longer putting pressure on the e-file
anymore and because blacks position
remains passive it's very likely that
white can use his better activity to
develop a real powerful initiative good
move here for why it would be 94 and the
threat with this move is f4 and after we
move our knight on e5 White's going to
play Knight f5 the double attack on the
rook on e7 and the checkmate on g7 so
something like this would be really good
for white and if you can see this during
your game well now it's time to think of
a better defense if you have one right
so at this point we realize that the
simple move ninety five just isn't going
to cut it it's not a good enough defense
and even if it was a decent defense even
if
this move didn't lead to a huge powerful
initiative for white you should still
look for a more active solution to your
problem you should try to find a way to
not only defend the pond but cause some
kind of issue for white so the move
played in the game and by the way
playing black here is Manuel Lasker the
second World Champion is rookie 5 this
is an absolutely brilliant move and
fully emphasizes the point of why the
active solution is almost always the
best one so how does this move defend
the c7 pawn it defends it indirectly
Knight takes c7 and still fails either
to rook c5 or rook c8 and Queen takes e7
is bad because we can simply take the 9
on b5 and our queen and everything in
our position is defended in black wins
apiece
so this defends the pawn but ok the rook
looks silly on e5 right I mean just
because we indirectly defendant upon
doesn't mean it's a good move but the
point of behind this move is very tricky
and I want to go over the rest of the
game just to show you how things played
out so 94 was played and now rook c5 so
this rook is activating itself along the
C file and eventually black is going to
be able to get his Queen out and bring
his other rook to the e-file so this
move this maneuver riki 5 to c5 was a
way for black to gain some activity for
his pieces and gain some time to get
himself back into the game and try to
fight for the initiative now Queen b3
and Knight b6 now why plays f4 so this
move gives a lot of danger to black
right white is controlling this a 5
square which means this rook no longer
has any way to get back home and it
means it's exposed but concretely the
Rick is safe why it doesn't have an
actual way to trap this rook so Queen f6
Queen f3 and rook e8 and this is sort of
the culmination of black strategy three
or four moves ago he had a very passive
position and it looked like why it was
well on his way to launching this you
know decisive attack in the center in
the Kings side and now a couple of moves
later all the blacks pieces are in the
game and it's actually white OS to be
careful here because the center is about
to become under pressure from blacks
pieces so c3 was played a 5 B 3 a 4 B 4
and rook c4 so this pawn advance a5 a4
took control over the c-4 square for the
rook g3 and now rook d8 this is a very
strange-looking move but the idea behind
it is pretty incredible
like just wants to play c5 and this
causes total havoc to White's position
because the c3 pawn is going to be under
attack once this Knight moves and
opening up the Queen and the rook is
going to be open up on the D file and
all of White's pieces in the center are
suddenly under serious pressure rook III
was played and c5 Knight b5 C takes b4
and now I played rook takes d6 and e5 so
the last few moves were pretty much
based on tactical considerations I
didn't really go into detail because
it's not sort of the subject of this
video and I just wanted to show you guys
how the game progressed and once
everything opened up it turns out that
blacks pieces were sort of better
coordinated to deal with the
explosiveness of the center of the
position and the tactics worked out here
for black so if you want I would
strongly recommend here to pause the
video again and find the best move for
black to pretty much win the game
okay so white is forking the two pieces
here and then if black makes a simple
move like queen g6 he's probably going
to be okay but then why can play Knight
takes D six and the position becomes
really unclear and I'm not actually sure
who's going to be better if black makes
a simple move like Queen g6 but lasker
again found the most active solution to
this problem and this time again it was
based on tactical opportunities so the
move plan in the game and the strongest
move is rook takes f4 and the point
behind this move is that after white
captures this rook black has queen g6
check getting his Queen away from the
fork with check and after white moved
this King he played Queen b1 check
rip d2 check and he took this pawn and
the position we were left with here
after a3 is completely waiting for black
he's got two extra pawns but what's
important here is that this a pawn is
very strong and white was unable to stop
this pawn from queening and those black
won the game so again the point of this
video was to discuss this position back
here white play this move Queen c3
making a threat against the c7 pawn and
instead of defending the pawn the
routine or mundane way would 95 which
would lead to a pretty bad position for
black Lasker found a very active
solution to his problem he played rookie
v activated this rook and got enough
time to seize the initiative by bringing
out his other pieces very quickly thanks
a lot for listening and I'll see you
around on chess calm